okay guys justin here with a gamespot
news update nintendo president satoru
iwata has said that they plan on
releasing a new console in emerging
markets by as early as next year
nintendo wants to develop new consoles
and games aimed at the rising middle
class in regions without a large
existing video game market deewana
didn't discuss specific hardware details
but said it'll be difficult to enter
those markets if we didn't create
something new you need to provide
something that most of the middle class
can afford you wanna also said there are
no plans to launch existing hardware
such as the Wii U or 3ds in these
markets such as China he expressed an
interest in the large Chinese gaming
market but said i don't think the
lifting of the console ban has solved
all of the difficulties and entering it
we need to study it more Microsoft has
partnered with a Chinese company to sell
its Xbox one in China buddy wada said
for us Microsoft's approach wouldn't
work Nintendo has just posted their
third consecutive year of operating
losses Annie wada has gone on record
saying that he feels deeply responsible
however they will be doing a digital
presentation at e3 this year and
GameSpot will be on hand to cover it